ja und jetzt schauen wir auf unseren
bundeskanzler olaf scholz auf dem
baltikum ist man schon lange in
alarmbereitschaft gegenüber russland
jetzt besucht unser kanzler vilnius und
trifft alle drei staats- und
regierungschefs aus litauen lettland und
estland das deutsche vorgehen im krieg
steht dort durchaus in der kritik
bundeskanzler olaf scholz ist dort
angekommen eben in der hauptstadt von
litauen es ist der erste besuch des
kanzlers in den östlichen nato staaten
seit kriegsbeginn dort begrüßte ihn
heute morgen litauens präsident kitas
neuseeland präsidentenpalast und scholz
sagte die worte
was für uns ganz wichtig ist es
ebenfalls dass wir uns darüber
unterhalten wie wir den auf den
russischen angriff
reagieren indem wir alles dafür tun dass
russland diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
kann es muss den krieg beenden und seine
truppen zurückziehen das ist etwas was
wir mit der ukraine an deren seite wir
solidarisch stehen
verlangen es ist so dass deutschland
einer der wichtigsten militärischen
unterstützer der ukraine ist niemand
lieferten ähnlich großem umfang wie
deutschland es tut es gibt ein paar
wenige die auch sehr viel tun wie zum
beispiel die vereinigten staaten von
amerika aber deutschland zählt zu den
ländern die in ganz großem umfang ihre
möglichkeiten einsetzen wir haben mit
großem umfang geliefert
panzerabwehrwaffen luft märkte raketen
munition in riesigen mengen wir haben
flac panzer auf den weg gebracht und uns
darüber mit der ukraine verständigt und
diese bestellung ist jetzt auch
vorbereitet
also es geht wieder um waffenlieferungen
und da wird jetzt durchaus sehr brenzlig
für den kanzler bei uns im studio bild
chefreporter peter tiede der nicht nur
die baltischen staaten sind enttäuscht
auch jetzt gibt es kritik seitens
spaniens seitens griechenland über das
vorgehen der deutschen regierung wenn es
um die waffenlieferungen für die ukraine
geht ja wir dem deutschen kanzler
zugehört wird immer abwehrwaffen
abwehrwaffen abwehrwaffen flac panzer in
prag panthers auch eine abwehrwaffe die
ukraine hat aber das sagt der
bundeskanzler nicht gebieten und zwar
seit monaten um kampfpanzer also panzer
die nach vorne gehen indem man im feld
steht wie man an der front tatsächlich
auch braucht um an tatsächlich angriffe
zurück zu schlagen und da kommt jetzt
eine heikle nachricht aus madrid in
spanien hat angekündigt man wolle
leopard 2 panzer aus deutscher
produktion an die ukraine liefern und
das würde bedeuten dass der
bundeskanzler zustimmen muss das ist die
erste falle für den kanzler für die
liebende sagen wir mal so
panzersperre urlaub scholz denn er
müsste zustimmen weil es sind deutsche
panzer aus deutschen und ständen die
entfernt rolle wie das fach technisch
heißt liegt bei deutschland und damit
auch beim bundeskanzler und dann ist das
auch noch aus anderer sicht ein problem
denn die deutsche bundesregierung
erzählt uns ja jetzt seit wochen dass es
interne nato absprachen gebe informelle
absprachen wonach man sich verabredet
habe keine schwere technik also keine
kampfpanzer in die ukraine zu liefern
jetzt muss der kanzler die frage
beantworten bricht spanien da eine
informelle absprache oder gab sie gar
nicht denn außerhalb den deutschen kann
sich an diese absprache niemand erinnern
auch die beiden bei denen ja geradezu
besuches können sich daran auch nicht
erinnern
das ist die spannende frage also wenn
wir jetzt müde spielen würden wäre jetzt
in der zwickmühle eigentlich kann man
sich nicht mehr bewegen wenn er das
jetzt ablehnt dann ist er endgültig da
wo man in europa die sind ohnehin schon
haben unser führungsrolle gerade in
dieser krise haben wir verloren der
kanzler hat ja recht wir geben ganz viel
geld aus und wir liefern ja auch sachen
ihnen aber wir haben eben auch
bestelllisten der ukraine und selbst
lieferlisten der deutschen industrie die
aufgelistet hat und was man liefern kann
so radikal zusammengestrichen
dass davon zum teil nur sechs positionen
von über 100 positionen übrig geblieben
sind und das gehört halt dazu und dann
gibt's ja noch ein anderes panzer
geschäft also bei weil olaf scholz die
liebende panzersperre in der nato und in
der europäischen union ist kommt es zu
einem ringtausch wir sind also
deutschland wird jetzt marder panzer
nach griechenland geben und griechenland
gibt dafür alte nva panzer also ddr
panzer aus den 70er jahren dann an die
ukraine jetzt sagen die griechen leute
ist ja schön und nett aber gebt eure
panzer direkt an die ukraine macht das
verfahren kürzer macht es einfacher und
macht auch ein billiger für uns weil wir
müssen uns dann keine neue munition
kaufen wir brauchen die alten rostigen
panzer auf den inseln nur als
abschreckungs waffe die kann man aber
nicht in die vorderste front stellen das
hat uns oder unsere kollegin in
griechenland liliana das büro polonia
für uns arbeitet korrespondentin hat
dass ein ehemaliger
verteidigungsminister gesagt und auch
einer der namhaftesten militär analysten
des landes von griechenland sagt das ist
kompletter kokolores das ist unsinn
mumpitz und macht es doch einfach mal
anders also der kanzler liegt er voll im
beschuss und das blöde ist wir sind mit
dem verschissen wie sehr schadet diese
deutsche blockadehaltung dem ansehen von
deutschland aber noch viel wichtiger wie
sehr einen das einfluss auf den
kriegsverlauf auch also man muss sich
langsam wirklich fragen warum wir immer
sachen erst auf internationalen druck
machen erinnerung vor kriegsausbruch hat
estland darum gebeten alte hauptsitzen
das und panzerabwehrwaffen die dinger
mit zum langenrohr wo man vorne so ein
paar kann man 40 kilometer schießen mit
die werden fortfahren die mich dann auch
gegen panzer und gegen stellung
angesetzten die aus nva beständen aus
den 70er jahren neun stück symbolisch an
die ukraine liefern zu dürfen wer als
blockiert wir immer blockieren wir uns
immer liefern wir erst auf druck dann
wirklich sachen und wirklich also wenn
es nicht mehr anders geht dann liefern
wir und unsere da vorgeworfen
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz unrecht dass
wir damit auch der ukraine wirklich
massiv schaden die panzer sind die
deutschen panzer von denen wir immer
behaupten oder unsere regierung werde
nicht aber unsere regierung behauptet
die ukraine könnten die nicht fahren ja
wenn wir die frühzeitig geliefert hätten
und die leute frühzeitig ausgebildet
hätten dann könnten die seit wochen
wahrscheinlich schon seit zwei monaten
mit diesen panzer an einer front fahren
und sicher wären wir haben verhindert
vielen dank für diese einschätzung zu
diesem thema